[Música]
quer transformar sua saúde salve o
número 1194 22950 e86 na sua agenda e
não se esqueça de rever os textos e
links enviados na consulta dias atrás se
não tiver recebido por favor me cobre
na sua alimentação com uma dieta
equilibrada cortando industrializados
glútem derivados do leite farinos e
açúcares se exercite frequentemente
mesmo que seja somente uma caminhada de
30 minutos por dia e você pode fazer
isso em qualquer lugar em com qualquer
calçado confortável o gerenciamento do
estresse é fundamental e a meditação é
crucial para você manter o equilíbrio
comece com um minuto à noite antes de
dormir meditação é de graça e ficar
nervoso custa caro paraa sua saúde não
se esqueça uma boa noite de sono é
indispensável Desligue as luzes e telas
uma hora antes de dormir e crie um
ambiente tranquilo silencioso e com
temperatura adequada Deixe o celular
carregando em outro cômodo para mais
dicas valiosas e conteúdos exclusivos
reveja o material dado na sua consulta e
acesse o blog artigos p aluru
comom E também o meu canal do YouTube